more than 3 000 people have died of
covet 19 in india in the last 24 hours
a new record for the country this makes
india only the fourth country in the
world after the united states
brazil and mexico to cross 200 000
deaths
during the coronavirus pandemic this at
a time that india added more than one
million cases
in just the past week alone the reality
of these
deadly numbers plays out in india's
hospitals and medical facilities
every day stretched to the limit they
are running out of supplies
primarily oxygen people desperate for
assistance have turned to social media
please for help are being posted and
those who can
are responding with information on
platforms like facebook
instagram and twitter
such as this user in mumbai who's saying
that oxygen is available for those in
delhi
at the sikh temple in gaziabath city in
northern india
this user in the southern city of
bangalore posting verified information
about someone who can help deliver
medicines to elderly patients
staying alone and this group of covert
volunteers
in pune in western india with again
verified information about beds and
oxygen being available
in the city of nagpur in western india
and joining me now the person
responsible for that last tweet you saw
nitesh singh
from team sos india he joined me from
pune in western india and we also have
ayangar who's working in the city of
bhopal in central india
to help those battling the current covet
crisis welcome to both of you
nitish i'd like to come to you first how
are you collecting information and being
able to verify
what you are posting
okay so basically uh team assets india
have 120 volunteers so they
are spread across like across nation
and what they do is they collect
information uh like
we if we get any information on social
media or
we uh like call hospitals or
uh you can see labs and every everywhere
and we verify those details so every
detail that i've spreading all over
internet we collect them
and we verify them and then we post
those information on twitter
now pooja as i understand you are doing
much the same thing as nithesh
in bhopal but you're also helping out
with a community kitchen
in your city yeah we are a group of 150
volunteers and some of them are
helping with getting ventilators and
beds for people
but there are a large number of
attendants who are starvating
outside the hospitals they are not
allowed to go in and their family
members are inside and it's a long
endless
wait and since it's locked down and
there are no shops open so we start
decided to start a community kitchen for
them it's a crowd-sourced thing
and people have generously donated and
we have started a kitchen where we can
give them
food water lunch all these things so
that you know the weight
becomes a little bearable
as i understand it you set up team sos
india last year
as the first wave of covet infections
was
hitting india and i need to mention here
that you are in pune in maharashtra
state which is
possibly the worst affected state in
terms of covet infections in
india did you ever imagine that things
would ever get
this bad
so like when the first wave like ended
we were like
we will not hear about this covet again
like
since the vaccination was started people
are getting vaccinated
so we never thought that we will see the
second wave
let alone this uh like uh this much
impact
like it was not we have imagined
it it is something that uh hits me hard
as well
because i would never have imagined like
you nitesh potentially that things would
ever
become as bad as they are in india and
therefore puja i wonder if you think it
is essentially
left to citizens such as yourself and
nitish to
organize help because the system is not
being able to cope
it's a huge crisis and
the government is doing what it can and
to the best of its ability and i feel
that everybody has to
join hands and you know somehow
tackle the situation and we are sitting
at home we are receiving calls and
sometimes
people are just panicking also so we
take those calls and give try to give
them some emotional support because
in our family also so many people are
covet positive and everybody has gone
through a similar uh
thing so we can you know counsel them
help them
and the entire country has to unite and
everybody has to stand together the
government
is doing what it can uh but we also have
to rise to the occasion
i feel like personally for you i mean as
puja was saying
i think nearly every indian knows
somebody who's been affected
by this crisis what is it like for you
to be able to run this network of
volunteers and to provide information
to other people knowing full well that
people in your circle
might be affected
so uh like recently my fiance got a uh
like uh
she she got coveted uh last month
so it was a paid like uh i never thought
like
uh that in my family i will see someone
like we are taking every precaution and
everything so
this is something even i can't i cannot
say
this is something i told you that we
cannot imagine what
what is happening around every day we
are facing new problems
pooja do you think india could have been
better prepared for a potential second
wave
i am actually the first uh wave that hit
us it was more of the migrant laborers
and we were
you know we it it came as a jolt we
uh were trying to prepare
ourselves but we didn't know that the
situation will get this bad because the
first it wasn't so severe
so i didn't i don't think anybody
expected this like right now my mother
is cobit positive
and i am going through the same uh thing
and there are so many others also
and it's happening in every house so the
magnitude of this thing nobody could
have imagined
yeah nitish one last a question to you
do you think the work that you are doing
through team india sos
will only keep expanding and
the work that you will have to shoulder
on a daily basis
will only become more and more as we go
along into the next few weeks
uh yeah i can tell you that because we
are expanding our volunteer networks i
told you that we have data team of 120
people then tech team of 20 people then
we have data
analytics team of 20 people then we have
team which handle bed plasma and
blood request so we have like right now
and a total sin we are
6 27 70 more people are joining in today
so and we even though we have this much
strength we are not able to like we have
still faced like
the work is more and we have left people
with us
we leave it there for the time being but
thank you so much for joining us uh
nitesh singh and uh pooja younger thank
you very much
both of you for the work that you're
doing for fellow citizens
thank you let's take a closer look at
this with smoothie
chalini who is a community organizer in
delhi who helps
organize resources via social media
welcome to
dw what are people most in need of when
they contact you
uh they mostly contact us for
well last week it was rtpcr at home
collection
test this week it is um
oxygen cylinders and i'm afraid to say
now
it's mostly uh they there's a cry for
help for
our ventilators and hospital admissions
whereas you know that the there's only
so much that our health care
system can uh support right now so
uh we are still trying our best that
we uh identify uh the need
at a at a right time wherein we don't
have to wait for things to get
to worsen and uh so that we can
you know just help them uh when they
need it
and when it can actually help them
there's no point in getting an
oxygen cylinder to them uh when the spo2
levels have to drop to 40. so uh that
that's something that is
uh very uh distressing to even uh people
like us who are helping uh
people on through social media but
um that's uh one thing that we are
finding
ourselves uh very uh distressed about
uh that people are crying for help
and it's a it's a shame that people are
dying not just because of covet
but because of the lack of treatment and
resources for gold
that's the most unfortunate part of this
old crisis
and and as if to make exactly uh that
point i i'm aware that you've recently
lost your own grandfather to covet and
he was he was quite a man
yes he was he was uh the past president
the past national president of the
indian medical association
which is the only national
representative voluntary organization
for the doctors of
modern medicine and he has
he had dedicated life to uh public
service that the thousands and lakhs of
patients that he has
uh treated and uh he was 90 years old
and i don't know how long he would have
lived uh
it's unfair to even uh say that he would
have uh
you know make assumptions but what uh
saddened me was that a man of such
stature he had to
uh leave us and in such a sad manner
because
for the lack of oxygen i myself must
have called
50 numbers and the helplessness with
which the
vendors replied for oxygen refilling
was something that i can't even blame
them for
they don't have oxygen where do i get it
from
where do they get it to me from so
that was a very unfortunate thing but i
hope
uh it went to somebody who was
who was more in need and my grandfather
would have wanted
the very same thing for it to be to
reach someone who was
uh more in a way that who would have
made
more use of it if i can put it like that
you can indeed and we're sorry for your
loss and thank you so much for joining
us
uh sriti shalini in delhi thank you so
much
with india struggling countries around
the globe have been lining up to provide
help
oxygen equipment and other supplies have
arrived from the uk with more on the way
from australia
germany and other countries
also the worldwide indian diaspora is
contributing what it can
here some london-based volunteers
sharing their experience
the temple was very quick in setting up
a fundraising campaign
and you know it was overwhelming support
our online websites the telephones here
at the temple were
ringing hard and fast i have phone calls
coming from my
pakistani friends and muslim friends
they want to help as well they say look
look rajneesh please advise which
charity we can do it we want to do it
because it's it's it's not it's you it's
not
your problem is it's united it's a
humanity problems whatever we can do
we should help it is so so yes they are
coming together
we had reached over a hundred thousand
pounds of donations
which we transferred quickly to india
and um
got translated into medical provisions
non-medical provisions
uh therapeutics so people you know
in india were able to benefit from the
donations of the british asians
and while those donations make their way
into india the virus
begins its spread outside there's
concern in neighboring nepal
after a rapid rise in corona virus cases
attributed to the strain of the virus
causing havoc in india
the nepalese capital kathmandu is
already struggling with increased
hospital admissions and resources
stretched thin
nepal bracing for another wave of
coronavirus infections
citizens in kathmandu are lining up to
get their tests
hoping to be negative as cases surge in
a rapid speed
the sharp rise viewed by the more
infectious mutant strains from
neighboring india
border cities have already become hot
spots and doctors fear that the capital
will soon
the follow at the border town of
nepalgange reflects what's happening in
india
and i call it mini india
if the same thing replicates in a
densely populated city like kathmandu
the situation would become much more
difficult
vaccine efforts in the himalayan state
are complicating the situation
about seven percent of nepal's
population have so far received a shot
but the country is struggling to procure
more doses
as it relies on supplies from india
there authorities have prioritized their
own needs
as the situation runs out of control
that could soon be the case in nepal if
the trend continues
in kathmandu the health system is
already stretched
people are struggling to find hospital
beds for their sick family members
we brought him to the hospital in an
ambulance as he was facing briefing
difficulties
the doctors haven't attended to him
everyone's busy busy
and worried as the more infectious
variants
also hit young people and children
harder than before
it's a crisis that's set to become worse
here
before any improvement
you